vous connaissez bien roulé fait non je
connais des tarifs très bien ah ouais
les airs de conte était tarifs je le
fais moi moi j'ai fait les paupières à
cause de vous c'est fait les paupières
parce que c'est loupé un regard
malicieux c'est super ça lui donne un
regard des questions au dr ya pas un nom
en données où ça change la personnalité
parce que il est en règle générale il ne
supporte pas de se voir avant c'est à
dire que il gomme complètement l'image
d'avant magali est ce que tu assumes
toutes les photos qui a de toi avant où
es tu te retrouves face facilement ou
pas du tout en fait j'ai du mal mais
j'avais rappelle-toi j'avais j'étais pas
bien en plateau un jour au tir il avait
mis une photo de moi avant mais en fait
ça me oui ça me fait ça me blesse parce
que je n'ai très mal vécu j'étais
j'étais pas bien dans mon corps et dans
ma tête donc appartient au moment où je
suis malheureuse j'estime que j'ai le
droit à mon âge de refaire ce qu'il faut
pour me sentir bien si ses patrons
français 35 ans a passé cinq ans oui
mais même une fois 35 ans de souffrance
pour aller mieux
non elle alors qu'elle a eu envie
d'aller mieux tout de suite j'ai pas
envie d'attendre
voilà qui aurait tué nombreux noms
commencent à souffrir ou encore compensé
téléspectateurs et où pour 10%
c'est très peu contre 90% voilà bombail
à 10%
c'est déjà pas mal ça va